this is the giant propeller advanced sl0
a first for the manufacturer giant has
remoulded its famed TCR into a
full-fledged
aero bike for the 2013 racing season
instead of their well-known compact
geometry they've employed a straight top
to airfoil tube shapes brakes modeled
off of team only straight full systems
and integrated cabling and bar stem
systems add to further improve
aerodynamics the bike comes fully
equipped with an improved Shimano di2
and giants own 50 millimeter P SLR
carbon rims although you'll likely see
pro riders on another set of wheels this
is not a climbing bike so look for in
the flat sprinter stages of the tour
starting now it's a spendy bike worth it
if you're riding into flats all day or
just happen to have an extra 10k laying
around